(comical music)
- Uh, yes, hello?
Hi, um is this, IT?
Hi IT, this is Elliott.
Yeah, yeah I was just wondering,
who do I call to find out
how to work the phones?
Well, I don't know.
No, no, I'm not crying.
Yeah no, I know it's part
of my job to call clients.
Yeah, I know that I'm
on the phone right now.
But when you're in an elevator
do you know exactly how that works?
Hello? Hel, hello?
Dammit.
God.
- Do you honestly
not know how the phones work?
- What? Oh Shh ah Shh.
- It's okay, don't worry.
Don't cry or anything, I got it.
Here, here, I got it.
(chuckles) All better.
- [Elliot] Thanks.
- No problem.
Have a good one.
- No problem, have a good one.
(chuckles)
I will Anna, I will have a good one.
- Come on!
- Hey there Harper,
you having some trouble
with the old copy guy?
- Yeah, it's not working, as always.
- You wanna step aside
and let me give it a shot?
- Yeah, go for it please.
- All right.
(tapping)
- Oh!
- [Elliott] Boom!
- Hmm.
- [Elliott] It's working.
Did it, Elliott fixed the copier, guys.
- Your fly.
- [Elliot] Thanks Harper,
let's do one of these.
All right.
- We got a call from corporate
about yesterday's reports
because they found a
discrepancy inside the numbers.
- Oh yeah, I straightened them out.
- What?
- [Elliott] They were just
using the wrong algorithm, so
the error was on their side.
- You called corporate?
- [Elliott] Yeah.
- And talked to a person?
- [Elliott] Yep.
- And you didn't cry?
- Nope, no tears.
- You are feeling yourself, dude.
- Wow.
- (groans) No problem,
have a good one.
- Uh, the meeting is not over.
- Hey Elliott, hey.
- Hey Harper.
- Um, your fly.
- Ah no, you're fly.
- No, your pants fly is open.
- How long has it been?
- I don't know, I tried
to tell you this morning.
- Elliott fixed the copier, guys.
- Your fly.
(chuckles)
- (groans) No problem.
Oh no, no, no, (sobs) oh no!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay.
(phone ringing)
What, hello, what, what is it?
I don't, yes, no this is Elliott.
Oh yeah, that's, sorry.
(laughing)
I'm sorry.
- The discrepancy is coming
from inside the numbers!
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] All right, here we go.
(vintage film reel sounds)